foreign
it was for praising those committing
this attack on the U.S Capitol that led
to former president Donald Trump being
banned from Facebook and Instagram we're
going to the Capitol but now he's
allowed to return as the company says Mr
Trump's accounts no longer pose a
serious risk to Public Safety we're not
a truth police what we do have an
obligation and a responsibility is to
make sure that people don't use our apps
and our services in a way which can lead
to real world harm we hope it strikes
the right balance between free and open
debate but making sure that the rules of
our of our apps and services are
properly abided by breaking those rules
will mean harsher penalties but he may
choose to reject the invitation
altogether Mr Trump hasn't used Twitter
since their ban was lifted instead he
stuck to his own social media platform
but this time it may be tempting to
return Donald Trump's own platform is
never done particularly well it's only
ever really had a reach of a couple of
million people the truth is that
Facebook has a reach of 2.5 billion
people so a thousand times more he needs
the social amplification of Facebook and
Instagram speaking to Sky's Beth Rigby
about Kanye West's anti-semitic tweets
Jewish comedian David bediel says it's
this reach that platforms need to be
more mindful of I'm bothered about like
what is dangerous for Jews what is
dangerous for my children but is Kanye
West I think he's doing something better
no obviously I do think it's dangerous I
think it's actively dangerous
users will wait to see if Trump makes
his comeback but with another
presidential election on the cards every
platform could be valuables